selon votre groupe sanguin vous pourriez
avoir plus ou moins de chance d'être
infecté par le copil c'est ce que de
nombreuses études et article cherche à
démontrer depuis plus d'un an
mais comment expliquer le lien entre les
différents groupes sanguins et le co
vide et quel a été son influence sur sa
propagation
on essaye d'y voir plus clair dans
facture comprendre le lien entre le
risque d'infection covit 19 et les
groupes sanguins
il faut tout d'abord se pencher à
nouveau sur nos cours des étés les
groupes sanguins correspondent à un
autre et d'anxiété biologie les coupes
sont guère y en a une quarantaine
et quand on dit groupe sanguin ab haut
c'est un groupe sanguin et chaque groupe
sanguin est caractérisée par un ensemble
de substances qui sont soit des sucres
souhaitent des protéines donc dans ce
groupe ce hangar à bo
il ya deux substances qui le caractérise
il ya la substance à est la substance b
un individu qui est à la substance à
roche il est bcp si léo une amie annie b
d'autre part ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que le l'association ou sanguin
maladie c'est connu depuis très très
longtemps donc quand on émerger ses
études au tout début de la pandémie sur
une plus grande fréquence à dire 200
garçons n'étaient pas franchement étonné
le lien entre le risque d'infection
convient de 19 l appartenance à un
certain groupe sanguin est donc une
question qui a été soulevée dès le début
de l'épidémie il faut tout d'abord se
demander comment le coc viennent nous
infecte par le centre dont un virus donc
infecte les cellules d'un autre eh bien
il utilise en fait que la machinerie de
l'autre pour proliférer se reconstituer
pour faire son enveloppe
il ya des sucres qui sont branchés sur
toute l' enveloppe la protéine enveloppe
et si un individu par exemple eh bien il
va plutôt branché des sucres 1 sur les
virus
le virus se transmet très bien dans des
conditions compatibles fait le même
système que pour la transfusion sanguine
si vous voulez sauf que là on a un
bonheur et un receveur
donneur non pas un bonheur de se former
de virus en maintenant ce sont près
d'une quarantaine d'études qui ont été
publiées sur le lien entre le colis de
19 et le sang tout basé sur différentes
hypothèses
par exemple une étude menée par les
chercheurs canadiens et publiée en mars
2021 a démontré qu'il existait un risque
diminué d'infection du groupe sanguin o
mais les onze sont des donneurs
universels jusqu'à personnes bio si vous
voulez donc les eaux
une seconde étude menée par des
chercheurs de l'université de médecine
de harvard a déterminé que contrairement
au groupe o le groupe sanguin a aurait
lui ait plus de chance d'être infectés
par le virus et ce à un effet visible en
france où le groupe a est le plus
fréquent mais sont relativement or ce
fait à peine 10% et pour les groupes à b
et b qui sont beaucoup moins fréquents
dans la population française
il n'existe que très peu de statistiques
en fait qu'ils sont en théorie les puis
jacques liste parce qu'elles sont les
personnes de groupe ab qui n'ont ni anti
onu au tibet et au delà de l'influencé
sur l'infection au co vide
on apprend dans une étude française
publiée dans le journal of clinical mais
des signes que notre groupe sanguin
influence également les chances de
développer une forme grave du coc bild
dans cette étude par exemple les sujets
étaient des patients hospitalisés
infectés par le cos vide qui avait
précédemment été opéré pour un
remplacement de valve aortique
l'étude démontre que le fait
d'appartenir au groupe a était un
facteur de mortalité prédictif les
groupes nombreux
une fois que la maladie sévère est
installé s'en tire plutôt moins bien
donc les vidéos il a été montré que les
facteurs de la coagulation ou qui
permettent d'empêcher les saignements et
bien il on dirait que vit un petit peu
inférieur dans le sens des individus aux
dons qu'ils ont moins de risques dans la
population générale de faire des combos
des accidents cardiovasculaires que les
indics tu as maintenant qu'on en sait un
peu plus sur le co vider les groupes
sanguins
on peut se demander si ce lien et en
impact déterminant sur la propagation
d'épidémies
l'ensemble des interactions sous les
transmissions qui ne se font pas
finalement ralenti l'épidémie au fond ça
revient un peu au même type de
ralentissement que ce qu'on a on portant
un masque ou avec quelques gestes
barrières ça ne m'atteint pas à
l'épidémie mais cela à lentille est ce
que ce lien a été déterminant à
l'échelle mondiale eh bien oui parce
qu'il y aurait une corrélation entre la
fréquence des groupes sanguins et
l'impact de l'épidémie parce que selon
la région les fréquences de groupe
sanguin varie énormément en asie par
exemple les répartitions de groupes
sanguins sont à peu près équilibré donc
la question du lien entre locaux vides
et les groupes sanguins ne se pose pas
autant qu'en amérique du sud où il ya
beaucoup dansé strahl it et
amérindiennes et où plus de 70% de la
population et du groupe sanguin o
et comme on l'a dit plus tôt dans la
vidéo les eaux sont des donneurs
universels pour les transfusions
sanguines
mais aussi quand il s'agit de collines
les eaux vont se transmettre entre eux
sont protection par ces anticorps
naturels entre identité et du coup
l'impact est énorme dans ce pays
maintenant qu'on sait qu'on est plus ou
moins susceptibles d'être infectés par
le cos vides selon notre groupe sanguin
il ne faut surtout pas penser qu'on est
immunisée si on est du groupe pro ou
plus exposés si on est a dit non il faut
pas changer son comportement en fonction
de son groupe sanguin puisque comme je
le disais à l'échelle individuelle
finalement ça n'a pas beaucoup
l'important c'est à l'échelle de la
population au canal collective que ça
compte
au fond un peu comme une mesure barrière
supplémentaire
[Musique]
on